George Michael might go on tour again
seven years after he died how is he
going to do that you ask well through
Holograms
already the band members in Wham Shirley
Kemp George Michael's best friend in
Wham suggested the idea and this was
backed by fellow backing singer Helen
Pepsi damak croquette who is also up for
this I think this speaks to our
culture's unwillingness to accept death
everybody's got to be eternally young
nobody can ever die Kanye West had a
hologram of Kim Kardashian's father
recite some words that I guess he had
written for it at Kim Kardashian's
birthday party and I thought man this is
really I would not like this as a
birthday present you miss your loved
ones who have gone and so it can be
really sweet in a way it can be really
nice and satisfying to see them again
but it's not
real they're dead they're really dead